I've had one experience where I was in
front of a room is one of these rootage
like of all the audiences it's a huge
convention of all the people who hire
people to speak at conventions right so
you nail it and it's a great honor to
get invited given the audience and if
you nail it you're doing you good for 10
years you know and I have never lost my
train of thought as badly as I love my
lost my train of thought that day where
I literally forgot everything and I look
at the audience and I look at the pad
and I look at the others I can't
remember what to say next
I would always default alike or just
tell another story anything random story
nothing I got nothing
you can't say um right you can't say
where was I you know and I'm looking at
it it's now now and it's getting worse
because now I'm stuck in my head right
and so what do I do I go right and so I
stop and I turn to the audience and I
said have you ever had that feeling
where you lose your train of thought and
you can't find it and heart starts
pounding and your brass starts sweating
and you feel a little sick to your
stomach I'm having that feeling right
now I said and it's the most wonderful
feeling in the world because I feel
completely alive I said when I do these
things and sometimes goes on the road
and I forget that I have to bring my
a-game every time and I've just lost my
train of thought worse than I've ever
lost it ever and I got to tell you it's
moments like this that I really
appreciate because it reminds me that I
am NOT an automatic and I'm not the boss
and I'm not holier than thou and I have
to work very very hard every time I show
up that's what's happening right now so
where was I and somebody screamed out
told me where I was yeah I got more
applause at that moment that I did at
the end
and that's part of it which is they want
you to succeed the audience wants you to
succeed they're rooting for you and if
you allow them to repeat it they will
continue to review but if you if you if
you snubbed them and tell them I don't
need you then they'll then they'll
respond appropriately